hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host john
carroll
i know i love the story i'm about to
tell so some of you may have heard it
before
but uh it fits in so well with today's
podcast
several years ago my wife jennifer was
the writer in residence
at the kavli institute for theoretical
physics in santa barbara jennifer is a
science writer
uh journalist and so her job was to put
on weekly
talks or seminars or whatever workshops
to help
the physicists at kitp in santa barbara
think about communication writing
different ways of telling their stories
to the outside world and you know for
the most part
the physicist went along with this you
know bemused but tolerant
um at one week she brought up a friend
of ours who is a
tv writer his job is to write tv shows
network dramas right hour-long tv shows
and again this is not something that
most of the physicists
had as an ambition that someday they
would be writing for tv
but what lit them up at some point as
they were listening to our friend talk
was
he explained the idea that there is a
theory
of writing an hour-long tv drama there
is structure there there are certain
pre-existing beats that you're supposed
to hit especially
when you have commercials built in at
certain time points
certain kind of action events need to
happen at the right time
certain kinds of character development
certain twists etc
it's not just it goes on this and this
and this and this there's an
overarching structure of course everyone
who's done a little bit of work in uh
writing novels or screenplays
knows about this the three-act structure
very famous in
hollywood dramas and so forth but the
idea that there was a theory
suddenly lit up all the physicists in
the room like oh okay so let's think
about you know how we can use this and
how we can tweak the theory and so forth
so i think that this idea of there being
a theory of storytelling
is useful not only if you want to write
stories and who amongst us hasn't either
taken a hand at trying to write fiction
or imagine that someday we would write
our big novel but any one of us who
consumes
stories also which is basically all of
us you you get a little bit more
out of what's going on behind the scenes
whether it's watching tv or reading a
novel
if you have some theoretical
understanding of what is going on along
the way
so today's guest charlie jane anders is
the perfect person to talk about this
stuff
charlie jane is a very successful
novelist in science fiction and fantasy
she's won all the awards the nebula the
hugo theodore sturgeon award
locus award lambda literary award and so
forth but more importantly for today's
purposes
she's extremely interested in the craft
of
storytelling charlie jane was one of the
original co-founders of
io9 the website and she did a wonderful
series of blog posts on how to construct
a story you're telling
and she's been doing a similar set of
helpful blog posts for tour.com more
recently
that will be turned into a book so she
has a book coming out it's not till
august but you can still think about it
a book coming out called never say you
can't survive
how to get through hard times by making
up stories again
very useful if you're actually writing
stories even fascinating if you're not
going to do it
and charlie jane also has this week
coming out an actual work of fiction
victories greater than death it's a
young adult novel the first in a trilogy
so we talk about you know all the usual
questions one has when one talks to
artists like where do you come up with
the ideas is it characters first is it
plot first
and of course the answers are intricate
and uh different for every little piece
of writing so
i i think this is going to be useful
whether or not you're a storyteller
yourself because in some sense
aren't we all storytellers really and
with that philosophy in mind
let's go
charlie jane anders welcome to the
mindscape podcast yeah it's so great to
be here
thanks for having me so the first
question we're going to talk about
stories the power of stories
i want to give the audience members a
little bit of inspiration and guidance
if they want to
become writers themselves right but uh
let's start with the softball question
what was your
pandemic binging what were the stories
that you turned to
in our time of lockdown for this last
year or so
oh wow i mean for the most part during
the pandemic i've been kind of
gravitating towards
like lighter entertainment things that
didn't you know upset me or depress me
oh yeah
a few exceptions so i've been watching a
lot of like things like
summer camp island and the second season
of hilda came out
i have no idea what these are what is
summer camp island summer camp island is
an amazing animated show you can watch
it on hbo max
it's also it was on cartoon network i
guess and it's about an island that's
like
just a perpetual summer camp which is
full of witches and yeti
and aliens and you know monsters and
ogre
like it's got everything and um it's
these two kids oscar and hedgehog
and their best friends and hedgehog
spoiler alert hedgehog
eventually becomes a hedgehog yeah sorry
eventually becomes a werewolf
she becomes a hedgehog werewolf hybrid
and
also she becomes a hedge wolf i guess
and like we're i don't know if she goes
to werewolf and she also becomes a witch
so she's she's got a lot she's a science
geek she
she actually runs a podcast on the show
she has a
special radio show that she hosts on
summer camp island that's all about
science it's called science talk
and it's her answering science questions
and that's like a running thing and so
i actually love the fact that there's
this character who is
a hardcore science geek who is obsessed
with astronomy and there's
episodes about her trying to you know
witness astronomical phenomena
and study science but she also becomes a
witch and is like super into like
learning how to cast spells and stuff i
think it's so great to have that
representation so you kind of go for the
uplifting uh version of your stories in
the pandemic yeah
yeah i think i mean you know yeah and
i've been reading a lot of y a
because i'm writing y and i wanted to
kind of why yeah he's younger
you know put y e in my brain while i was
re writing it so i
kind of had i kind of was maintaining a
kind of y a
tone or a voice or whatever sorry so why
a stands for young adult
that's right okay that's correct good
yeah no that makes perfect sense you
want to
you want to be thinking and listening in
the voice that you're speaking and
writing in right
mm-hmm so okay so for those of us
i mean so that the reason why i started
with that question is because
it illustrates the fact that it's
perfectly obvious a cliche that these
stories
play a role like they mean something to
us you know not to get too deep so i
kind of do want to be
hands on and and uh constructive here
for most of the podcast but
what's the big deal about these
imaginary stories that we make up i mean
do you have a theory about why we
care so much about stories like you
could read uplifting
real life things but why do we make up
fiction instead
yeah whatever happened to upworthy.com
reading upworthy right now
yeah i mean i think that stories are
part of how humans deal with
you know stress and how we deal with you
know
epistemic kind of you know crises and
challenges
and you know i think that we tell
stories in order to
figure out the way the world works and
to figure out like
kind of a schematic of life if you want
if you want you know and it's basically
like
storytelling is kind of an engine of of
it's a way of modeling reality it's a
way of modeling reality and it's a way
of kind of
showing like if you do this all this
will happen basically and you know
um there was actually a great you know
nobody remembers this
but so i was obsessed with doctor who is
a kid
and after tom baker stopped being the
star of doctor who
in the early 80s he went on to
host a a program about books
for a children a children's program
where each week they would
i'm not sure if they were i've never
actually seen it now that i think about
it i'm not sure if they were dramatizing
the books or if they were just reading
from the books
or what but it was a program to
introduce kids to books
and i never watched that program because
i wasn't in the uk at the time but i
was obsessively reading any like i would
go my parents were college professors
and i would go to the
university library and any kind of i
would go on the through the microfiche
and look for anything that mentioned
doctor who like i was like
a hardcore doctor who not when i was
like yay tall
you know and my parents would just you
know let me use the university library
to just
obsessively read everything that i want
to know about doctor who and so i read
this article that really stuck in my
head where tom baker
talks about this program that he's doing
that's to introduce kids to books and
he said this amazing quote books are
wonderful
because they save you from the tiresome
process of learning from experience
[Laughter]
you know because you don't you don't
need to go
like you know fight a dragon if you can
read a book about someone fighting a
dragon or you know you don't need to go
do like you can experience things
vicariously in a book
and then you know well gosh if i go and
do this this and this it's
not going to turn out great for me but
if i do this maybe it'll be okay and
like
you know you can kind of imaginatively
live through a lot of stuff that you
maybe wouldn't be able to live through
in real life either because it couldn't
happen in real life or because
you would be dead if you tried to do it
in real life no i'm 100 convinced that i
would be excellent in solving crimes
because i have watched so many uh
procedurals and mystery novels and
oh sure things like that i
and then you know that would you get it
that way no i like that answer that it's
a
not not a substitute but uh and you know
extra bit of an experience that we can
get by uh by imagining these scenarios
and
presumably what that says about science
fiction or fantasy or things like that
is that it just enhances the kinds of
experiences we can imagine beyond those
we could actually plausibly
do ourselves yeah and you know i mean
it's a cliche to say this but
people had not yet been into space when
we were
starting to write stories about here's
what it would be like to go into space
and like
you know i think like i i say this all
the time but you have to imagine
something before you can do it like you
have to imagine something before you can
do it and like also
you know i don't want to understate the
importance of escapism i think escapism
is is a really healthy impulse
especially when things are really bad
but
even when things are good escapism makes
us
our makes us bigger it makes our minds
bigger it makes ourselves bigger it
makes
and it makes you know our us able to
imagine ourselves in all these different
situations that we couldn't be in in
real life
and that just it's fulfilling in a way
that real life often really isn't
and so the ability to escape into a
story gives us strength and gives us
like inspiration to
to do awesome things in the real world i
think that people sometimes think that
you can either
have escapism or you can go out and
affect
great change in the real world and i
think that actually no it's more like
the two things go hand in hand like
being able to have escapism and
be able to escape into stories when you
need to
will give you the emotional resilience
to
to to go out and make the world a better
place in real life in
reality but as you said recently on your
own podcast you and emily newetts have a
wonderful podcast called
our opinions are correct well thank you
and uh you as you made the point that
science fiction did a terrible job at
preparing us for the pandemic right
yeah i mean you know i feel like
we're gonna look back at most of our
sort of pandemic
fiction and you know especially movies
and tv
um and kind of roll our eyes after
having actually lived through a pandemic
it's very different not saying that the
last ship isn't going to hold up
because that's a classic uh but
but you know i think that in general you
know maybe apart from that one
stephen soderbergh movie did i say his
name right continue
yeah you can edit me out saying did i
say his name right but anyway so
apart from that one uh soderbergh movie
i think that most pandemic fiction
you know cuts corners and kind of
dramatizes and takes some
and i think even the soderbergh movie
has some issues that people have pointed
to
um but i think that you know it's it's a
mistake to think of science fiction
as you know a purely didactic medium or
a purely didactic genre
that like you know nobody who watched
george melies a trip to the moon
had a really good understanding of the
actual process of
of traveling to the moon right like
nobody was like okay well now that we've
watched george mellies and we've seen
the little rocket hit the man in the
moon in the eye
that nasa can just go build that and we
can do it and like this is the
exact realistic simulation that we've
run here
it's more like it's just seeing that
makes people think oh
maybe i could go to the moon and maybe i
could you know maybe there wouldn't be
people in like
adorable weird costumes dancing around
on the moon once you get there
but you know maybe this thing that
is kind of like dramatized in this very
silly
you know unrealistic way it just puts a
bug in your
ear or whatever it puts a thing in your
head that like oh what if we could do
that in real life
you know it's the more the what if than
the like it would be exactly like this
kind of so i think this is yeah i think
that i completely agree
with that analysis and it is a universal
impulse to think of these stories and
share them
so much so that there's a bunch of
people
most people in the world i don't know
who think that they really could write
some novels if they wanted to right that
they have a novel in them
in a way that most people don't think
that they have a theory of dark matter
in them
uh but and it must it must rub you the
wrong way
as a writer um but but do you think that
most no it doesn't it makes me happy
that was my question do you think that
most people do have a novel in them if
only they
had some wherewithal about shaping it
and making it come to life
yeah i mean i think we human beings this
sense cheesy but human beings we are
literally made out of stories and some
of them are
true stories about things that have
happened to us but a lot of them are
stories that we've imagined or that
we've dreamed or that
have kind of formed part of this kind of
fabric of our
psyches and so yeah i think everybody's
got many novels inside of us
and i think that you know the thing is i
mean
i have to break that apart a little bit
which is that i think
as with most things like i don't think i
could ever be
a professional basketball player even
though i'm tall
and you know and you know maybe meet
other
criteria for being a basketball player i
there's certain i don't have the
coordination i don't have the kind of
you know i actually literally was
diagnosed with like
spatial integration issues when i was a
kid so i literally you know i'm
i'm actually like officially not
good at throwing and catching and doing
other stuff like that um
so but i think that most things that are
mental that involve
concentration that involve thinking
anybody can learn to do and it's you
know maybe some people have an easier
time than others and maybe some people
are good at like one aspect and not
other aspects and have to work on the
aspects they're not good at
but i think that you know i mean anybody
could
if they really worked at it be good at
math anybody who really worked at it
could be good at writing
i think that you know it just takes a
lot of work
i think that people who don't haven't
tried to write a novel or who haven't
written
spent like years like me writing novels
that never went anywhere or that never
got published
before finally getting a novel out into
the world um like people think all the
birds this guy was my
first novel when it's actually the sixth
novel that i
completed and you know revised and
submitted for publication
and really kind of tried to get
published um
people who haven't gone through that
process sometimes overrate the idea part
of it
and underrate the turning
the idea into a working piece of fiction
part
the course you know i think that those
who those of us who've done it a lot
will always say oh the idea is the easy
part which i think is true
and you know there's like there's the
story idea and there's then there's the
premise and then there's like the
premise as kind of expressed as a series
of
you know conflicts and you know
questions and
and incidents and you know emotional
catharsis and all that stuff and those
are each of those is kind of an order of
magnitude more difficult than
than the first kind of than the previous
one
the idea that you can buy a plane ticket
or go out for dinner and eventually get
reimbursed for it
by your employer by your business sounds
great right you're getting money back
for something that you did but
of course in the real world the idea
that you have to keep all the records
hand in your expense reports all that
stuff it's mind numbing it's soul
crushing it takes time
from the creative work that you'd like
to be doing and expensify is here to
help
expensify is the most widely used
expense management platform in the world
with over 10 million users
and the point is expensify makes it easy
for you to get paid back
with expensify you just take a picture
of your receipt as soon as you get it
and you toss it
better yet you can link your credit card
and they will automatically match the
receipt to the expense and submit the
report for you
there are extra features for the modern
day traveler such as automatic
international currency conversion
concierge for travel needs real-time
notifications and mileage tracking
so visit expensify.com mindscape to get
started with the free trial
that's e-x-p-e-n-s-i-f-y
dot com slash mindscape
where do you personally start with i
mean i know some people start with
characters you can start with a
setting you could start with a plot you
know a dilemma
uh is there do you have a process there
or is it sort of whatever comes
it really varies and i think you know i
would be a little bored if all my
stories started the same way or kind of
you know came out
came about through the same kind of
genesis or whatever
um you know most of the time for me i
think
i start out with a fun what if and you
know i have a bunch of word documents on
my computer where i've written down
oh here's a cool idea what if this
happened and
you know if i don't write those down i
forget them within a day or so usually
and i have some i swear there was one a
week or so ago where i was like oh this
is a really cool idea and i didn't write
it down and i don't know it's just gone
i've forgotten it i'm
just probably never i was like maybe
it'll come back to me and it now it's
been long enough that i think it's just
never coming back to me
and so it's just it's gone like tears
and rain but
so sometimes you'll have a what if and
you'll just
you know that's not a story that's just
a cool
what if and then you have to kind of
think about like how does this become an
emotional thing that's about people and
about like
personal experience and about like you
know how do you turn this into a thing
with
with a plot and with characters and with
something that
i feel invested in enough that i can
devote you know weeks or months or years
of my life to it
and you know the the classic example
that is is all the birds in the sky i
was like
okay what if there was a mad scientist
and a witch and they
you know were in the same story together
and at first i was like what if they
were enemies but then i was like okay
what if they were friends
and that was the thing where that got in
my head and just wouldn't let go and i
just i was actually working on a
different novel
and i had to kind of pause working on
that other novel until i wrote down a
bunch of stuff about this idea
because i had to get it out of my head
and i just knew that that was going
someplace
and and at first i thought of it as
primarily a genre exercise and
eventually turned into something more
personal and more kind of
emotional which i think is how it has to
happen for it to be any
good in the end um but then you know
there are stories where i start out with
a character and i'm just like okay who
is this person
why am i thinking about them and where
is this going to go um
and then you know sometimes i start out
with
a science idea or a science thing
and there's not really a what if like
like a what if in the sense of like
what if we all walked on our hands
instead of our feet or whatever or what
if everybody one day
started talking backwards or you know
those are just things that i'm throwing
out there those aren't real story ideas
that i've come up with
um but you know the big example that i
have is
um my second tour book the city in the
middle of the night which
basically that started from i had gotten
really obsessed with tidally lodged
planets which
you know we had written about a lot on
io 9 and
you know during the time that we had
been doing i o 9 i started working
on i o 9 in like mid 2007
like summer fall 2007 and
um you know by the time i left io 9 in
the spring of 2016
we had gone from like tightly like
planets i we'd always kind of known that
they were a thing
but we had learned so much more about
them in that time and there'd been so
many pieces of news that were exciting
and
we were finally learning more about
actual exoplanets in a way that we
i feel like we hadn't been previously or
at least there was a lot of news about
them
and so i was just like holy crap these
are so fascinating and
you know they're you know the most
common habitable planets
that you know are within our potential
reach
outside of the solar system so just to
be super duper explicit here a tidally
locked planet we're thinking of an
exoplanet where
one side of the planet faces its star
all the time so it's a hot side to cold
side
yeah and i apologize i was about to i
was sort of
meandering my way around to giving a
definition of a but i think i was
probably never going to get there so i
appreciate that but yeah it's highly
like planets like
it's like there's a dark side and a
light side and you know it appeals to
all these things that i'm obsessed with
about like
these really stark divisions and
dichotomies and about like
you know just like it felt the more i
thought about the more i felt like it
was like a fairy tale setting
that you have like eternal darkness and
eternal light
and it felt like a fairy tale realm in a
weird way
like being on one of these title like
planets and like you know
um so i spent so i started out with
basically a setting and i was like okay
i want to write a novel that takes place
on a tidally locked planet
humans have been living there for a long
time already we're not going to see
humans arrive on the planet we're not
going to see the space voyage to get
there
we're just going to be living on this
tide they lock planet and my original
kind of
spark was like okay what kind of
creatures were native to this planet and
how did we interact with them
and that was all i had and i didn't have
any characters i didn't have any like
plot
i didn't even have like a what if other
than
what if we were living on one of these
planets and there was a native
an indigenous life form living there so
i had to
it took me two years basically to turn
that setting into a story like and it
was
really kind of agonizing it was really
kind of excruciating and
i probably should have just given up and
been like i'm going to just
go write something that takes place in
oakland um
because that's so much easier to write a
story set in oakland and the story is
headed on
on another planet a thousand years from
now uh but i was just really obsessed
with that setting and i just kept
reading about it and kind of talked to
people about it
and finally i did find the story that i
wanted to tell
and then it all fell into place but that
was an example of me really coming at it
from a very different direction so
i think it varies that was a very long
reason answering no but actually
no that was the perfect length because
both of those examples i mean one
example is you had two characters a
a magician and a science person
uh and the other one you had uh the
setting of this
this dramatically different planet and
but in both cases your job is to turn it
into a story in either case do you have
a story so in either case
did the plot come first right but you
know we think
at the very simplistic level we almost
conflate the idea of a story with the
idea of a plot
and uh i mean maybe what i'm saying is
talk about plots a little bit and then
we'll
circle back to how you extract a plot
from your initial starting point which
is very
different yeah so the way i think about
it is the way i think
i think that you have the premise which
is like
there's a witch and a mad scientist or
you know whatever people are walking on
their hands instead of their feet
and that's that's or that's not even the
premise that's the kind of like the
spark or whatever
and then it becomes more of a premise
when
there's i guess it becomes more of a
story once there's a character involved
and once it's like
so whose story is this like say we're
telling a story about like one day
everybody starts walking on their hands
instead of their feet
is your story about the one person who
keeps walking on their feet
and everybody else is walking on their
hands and you're like they're the one
person who's like i don't know what's
going on and this is confusing to me
because i'm still walking on my feet
is your story about the first person to
start walking on their hands and
everybody else starts copying them is
your story about you know
somebody who is just a random person but
starting to walk on their hands messes
up their life in all these ways that's
like
interesting um or someone who's someone
who doesn't have any legs who is now
liberated by the fact that everyone's
walking on their hands right
someone who's who's an amputee or who
you know who's been
i don't know who's yeah so i think that
um and obviously there's this is there
that premise or that idea opens up all
sorts of questions around ableism that
we should that you'd want to unpack if
you were going to really investigate
this seriously
um but so basically you you try to find
a way in and you try to find a character
who
is affected by it in a way that seems
interesting or that seems like
they're kind of a an interesting vantage
point beyond just
like an every person who is affected by
this in the same way as everybody else
or somebody who you know this is going
to be they're going to be interesting in
some
unique way um and meanwhile you have to
kind of think about like
the larger implications and the second
order effects of like if this happened
how would everything else be different
how would like 20 million other things
that we do in the world
be transformed by this and i think that
and you have to kind of
kind of build it out into more of a like
you know a story where like
okay everybody's walking on their hands
instead of their feet or like everybody
starts speaking let's go with everybody
starts talking backwards because that's
that's you know it
brings to mind all those old led
zeppelin albums or whatever you know
everybody starts talking backwards and
it's like everybody's doing backward
masking all the time or something
everybody starts talking backwards and
it's like
satanic or something and that's not a
story because that's just
okay this thing happened the story is
everybody starts talking backwards and
a person has been separated from their
child and they can't find their child
because their child
is because all the ways that they would
try to find their child would require
them to talk forwards instead of
backwards like maybe their phone
can't understand them so the the the
story is not
everybody starts talking backwards the
story is i'm trying to get to my child
who is on the other side of the world
and my phone doesn't work because it
doesn't understand me talking backwards
and all these other things are
you know the fact that everybody's
talking backwards is making it harder
for me to do this thing that i need to
do
it has to be about a thing that's like a
specific like somebody has a thing that
they're trying to do or somebody has a
thing that's
that's their story that they're trying
to deal with and the global kind of
premise
is just kind of shaping that or
informing that otherwise it's not really
a story it's just a
there's a phrase that we used to use in
science fiction writing circles
back when i started out that people
refer to a hate story
which doesn't mean hate us in i hate
this story
hater spelled h-a-i-t-e
and it stands for here's an idea
the end and
you can there are there you they're
actually professionally published
stories that are hate stories
especially and get that published if you
are
skillful enough and if you can make the
idea seem cool enough and i think
i've honestly published one or two
stories where i would classify them as
hate stories
uh because i was basically just like
exploring an idea and then once i
finished exploring the idea i was like
that's uh
that's all i got see you later uh but
most of the time you don't want to write
a hate story you want to write a story
where it's like here's an idea
and here's how it shapes someone's life
and hears
the actual story is about someone who is
you know on their own journey and you
know and so
especially when it's a big idea like
that you can't really make that the
story you have to make that kind of the
the kind of spark that leads to other
stuff that becomes the story
well it's an interesting sort of
implication here that in some sense
we can use characters as the bridge
between a premise and a plot right
because
i think you know for people like me you
know sciency folks uh
maybe i would love to write a novel
someday i have other things
in the way so who knows it'll if it'll
ever happen but
plots are the hardest like i can even
imagine writing characters but
it's bizarre to me that plots are hard
because
i guess sort of the puzzle solving part
of my brain thinks that if i already
know what the solution is then it's not
that
interesting and and i'm i can't even
imagine being one of those writers who
just starts writing without knowing
where the end is going to be but
but maybe if you have both this premise
you know magic and science or
talking backwards or whatever and then
there's a person
with a desire right with with some
obstacles in their way
then it becomes easier to sort of fill
in how that becomes a plot or am i
am i going too far no i think that
you're exactly right i think that once
there's a person who has
you know wants and needs and you know
things that they're trying to
work out for themselves and it could be
anything from like
you know a kind of identity crisis
around like
you know who am i who do i want to be
anything from that
to i want to get this thing and these
obstacles are in my way
like that's when you're usually cooking
and that's that's often that is kind of
the hardest part
in a way because you have to really
believe in this person and their
goals or their desires or their kind of
like questions that they're struggling
with
because that's the engine of your story
and like you know
to some extent you have to feel the
urgency of this person's
you know needs in order to be able to be
invested in the story as a writer or as
a reader and i think that
i okay so you know i do kind of think of
plots in terms of
like you have a problem and then there's
a solution
you know and oftentimes i when i start
out i don't know what the solution
to the problem in the of the story is
going to be and that part of the fun for
me
is being right there with this person as
they're struggling or people as they're
struggling to kind of
find a solution to the problem that
they're dealing with and you know
i like it when i'm surprised by things
like i feel like
if i'm surprising myself that means that
the story is kind of cooking
like if there's no if i'm not being
surprised by what's happening usually
that means i'm on autopilot
and that i'm just kind of like
regurgitating stories i've read before
or that i'm just kind of like
chugging along in a linear fashion
without kind of like
there's there's not a lot of sparks
flying kind of if i'm not
being surprised by stuff that happens or
by solutions or by
issues that arise and you know you want
complications and you don't want
like part of why you have complications
is that when you get to the end and you
find the solution
it feels a little bit like a magic trick
where there's been all these hands
moving around
and stuff but i think that you know um
i mean usually the problem does contain
the seeds of its own solution a little
bit
and it's not like a murder mystery like
i think if i was writing a murder
mystery you can always tell
if someone has really kind of thought it
through when they wrote them
our murder mystery or if they just kind
of got to the end and they were like
through a dart at a dark boardwalk
this person's a murderer and i'm going
to come up with a specious explanation
as to how they're they're the murderer
i think if it's a murderer mystery if i
ever did really try to write one of
those
i would really try hard to
work that stuff out in advance like
before i wrote
the dead body falling on the floor with
the knife in the
between the shoulder blades i would
already know who did it and kind of
have an idea of why and you know i mean
i wrote i
actually one of my unpublished novels
had a little bit of an element of a
murder mystery
and i did end up kind of um
diagramming the whole thing from the
point of view of the murderer
just to understand like the logic of
from their perspective what they thought
they were accomplishing it
what and like because it drives me nuts
when
the antagonist or the kind of you know
when you're everything's revealed in the
end and the antagonist behaved in a kind
of random
arbitrary fashion just to make the all
the dots connect up it's like nope they
had to be
thinking rationally from their
perspective the entire time and
this situation arises so they did this
and so
so i actually was really invested in
that but i think that
yeah i think that if you're not writing
a murder mystery you know there is going
to be a certain amount of
the solution having to come out of the
problem and having to be like
something that feels plausible and
earned but the other great thing about
writing of course is
when you get to the end of your first
draft and you're like well actually the
solution was this thing
that i should have introduced 200 pages
ago
you know what you can go back in
revisions yeah and introduce that thing
200 pages earlier
and the audience will never know that
you didn't have that in your first draft
they'll never be like well but you know
and like
i think that oftentimes the thing that
you think is going to be like
the biggest problem for your characters
turns out to actually be the thing that
helps them to solve the
the the main problem in the end because
they can turn it to their advantage in
some way that's always a fun way to go
well i think that you make this point in
one of the podcast conversations that
there are some plots that are just like
it's a quest there's a thing you want
it gets the characters moving and it's
all about you know some combination of
the adventure and the witty banter along
the way
but there are there are other plots
where somehow it's related to the
characters right uh
somehow the the characters it means
something to the characters along the
way and that's a more fulfilling kind of
plot
yeah and you know i always like
characters to
maybe have a be a little bit selfish
like i i i get bored if a character
doesn't ever have their own agenda
that's kind of you know separate from or
orthogonal to the you know the main
action
like if if all the character wants is to
get the widget
that's going to do the thing yeah you
know i'm like okay sure i
get the widget is important the thing is
important you know
but at the same time on this is
something i struggle with a lot
because i find i have to find different
ways of doing this depending on the
story
i always want the characters to have
their own concerns and their own agendas
that are kind of they're
that are personal because then i care
more and
if i ironically or counterintuitively i
care more about the widget
if in addition to or separate from the
widget
they also want a pony or whatever you
know
and like this is the thing i don't want
to give too many spoilers for the sequel
to victories greater than death my young
adult book that comes out
in april but in the sequel to victory is
greater than death
there is a certain amount of there's one
character who
is on a quest and their quest is of
importance to basically
every living thing in the galaxy but
they have a side quest or they have
their own personal quest
that they are more personally invested
in because it is meaningful to them
personally
and i kind of lean into that the
personal quest because it's just more
compelling and interesting than the
you know thing that is of equal
importance to everybody in the entire
freaking galaxy if you're a business
owner you might be making running your
own business harder on yourself
than necessary don't let quickbooks and
spreadsheets slow you down anymore it's
time to
upgrade to netsuite netsuite by oracle
is the world's number one
cloud business system you don't need to
pay for multiple systems that don't give
you the information you need when you
need it
you can ditch the spreadsheets and all
the old software you've outgrown
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory everything you need in one
place
instantaneously whether you're doing a
million or hundreds of millions in
revenue
save time and money with netsuite join
the over 24 000 companies
using netsuite right now let netsuite
show
how they'll benefit your business with a
free product tour
at netsuite.com mindscape you can
schedule your free product tour
right now at netsuite.com mindscape
that's
dot com n-e-t-s-u-i-t-e.com mindscape
can we just talk a little bit about the
role of conflict in plots
generally um i remember being struck
years ago by a quote from david mamet
that every character
in every scene should want something and
not necessarily the same thing ideally
you know different things sometimes
they're working together and that's sort
of one
uh poll on the spectrum but i was struck
equally well by a comment on twitter and
i'm sorry i forget who is bi
like they're they really wish that more
movies would not have conflict in them
and i never heard that point of view
expressed before but
i mean so on the one hand why is
conflict such a driver especially when
you know you and i are probably on the
side of people who
uh we we want our characters to
basically be competent right and you
know trying to basically do good things
not like cartoonishly
villainous um so you have to sort of gin
up some conflict there and do we
overrate
conflict is it is just the easy way to
make a story exciting or are there
more subtle ways we should be taking
advantage of yeah i mean
i think that people often have a very
narrow idea of what conflict means
and when i was starting out as a writer
like my first attempt at writing fiction
i thought that conflict meant
specifically that people had to be
enemies or that they had to be screaming
at each other or that they had to be
really unpleasant to each other
and you know um actually
um cecilia 10 who's this amazing uh
writer of kind of
often she writes science fiction erotica
right now she's working on an
urban fantasy trilogy that is kind of
has
erotic elements but is just kind of
straight urban fantasy i think in the
sort of anita blake
mode and um she also
i think she still runs it although i
think she sold it but she has this
publishing company
plus the press that does erotic science
fiction anthologies
and um she um
she had so when i was starting out
writing um
back you know at the dawn of time um
she was doing an anthology of erotic
science fiction
and i was like oh i'm going to try to
write something for this and she had
something in the guidelines about like
wanting the stories to be you know to
have a positive view of sexuality and to
not
have like you know depict sexuality in a
kind of negative or
you know to make sure that it's
consensual but also just depict
sexuality in a healthy
positive way and somehow my neophyte
writing brain turned that into nobody in
this story can disagree about anything
even unrelated to the sex everybody has
to be like
completely like you know blandly
you know there can be no conflict and no
kind of you know
uh no disagreement of any kind in this
story and it was
i think i mean it's this is a this is a
tough
uh this is a high bar to get over
because i wrote so many terrible stories
back then but i think this might be the
worst story i ever wrote
um i i mean it's that's a that's that's
a that's a saying a lot
because i wrote a lot of really terrible
stories but i think it might be one of
the worst stories i ever wrote
and like you know it took me a long time
to realize that conflict is not just
people being nasty to each other it's
not just
people you know having
deep-seated hatred or like you know only
one of us
like it's not even the thing of like you
want this sandwich i want this sandwich
only one of us can have this sandwich
and for some reason we can't just split
it
like you know it doesn't have to be that
it can be very
conflict comes in many different forms
and a lot of times conflict is
is subtle a lot of times conflict is
you know between people who like and
appreciate and respect and admire each
other
and they just have a difference of
opinion about something
and i feel like in real life we have
conflict in a lot of situations where we
wouldn't necessarily
classify it as i was at odds with this
person it's more just like we had
we had a debate about this thing like
and you know this person thought that
this thing should go in the recycling
bin and i thought it should go in the
trash
and so we discussed it for 30 seconds
and that we don't register that as like
we had a conflict but that counts but
that is a conflict
and like you know if you think about
like for example um
becky chambers is uh i think they're
called it's the wayfarer tetralogy the
the series that begins with a long way
to a small angry planet
you know those books are very gentle and
very kind and very sweet and they were a
huge inspiration to me in writing
victories greater than death and some of
the other stuff i've written recently
and those books are full of conflict but
it's not conflict
on the sort of like we are now fighting
it's more like you know off the top of
my head it's been a few years since i
read
a long way to a small angry planet but
there's one character who is keeping a
secret
there's one character who is slowly
dying of
a thing that could be prevented but
their religion says it shouldn't be
prevented and
other people want to prevent them from
dying because they love this person
um at one point there is a thing where
they're i think attacked by
you know interlopers but for the most
part the conflict is
not of the kind of shouty you know we're
throwing things at each other conflict
it's it's much more gentle and subtle
and you know i think that we need to
broaden our idea of what conflict is and
how it can be done
i think that people who say that they
wish they had movies with less conflict
what they really are i don't want to put
words in someone else's mouth but i feel
like when someone says that what they're
really saying is i wish that the
conflict was general
gentler and less kind of you know
antagonistic
uh and more kind of you know because i
think that
there's one very specific type of
conflict that people think of when they
hear that
word yeah i think that's a great
attitude or perspective on conflict
because
it it is especially if you don't want
the cartoon or supervillain or even in
many of the
modern superhero team-up movies they
seem to just
feel the need to have the superheroes
punch each other at some point for no
specially good reason and
it's like all right let's get over that
we know they're going to team up okay
but uh but yeah but no conflict happens
at a million different levels in our
everyday lives and and
so there is a cliche but is it a truism
is it obviously true or
does it worth is it worth thinking about
that
conflict is interesting that this is
what grabs the reader's attention that
you know the fact
that there are different possible ways
to go and different characters want
different things
i think that you know what's interesting
is when someone has to struggle
and the struggle could again the
struggle could be very gentle it could
be very kind of
you know it could be a
cheerful struggle it could be a happy
struggle it could be a joyful struggle
it could be a struggle that is kind of a
slow boil
it doesn't have to be like you know
you know it doesn't have to be like we
are now wrestling or whatever
but you know i think that you know
there's that quote that faulkner
that often cited quacker at faulkner
court that all
storytelling is about the human heart
and conflict with itself and i think
that you know
characters who never have to make
choices
or have to kind of question themselves
or never have to
kind of work for their goals or
are not we can think of probably a
hundred exceptions to what i'm saying
but as a general rule characters who
don't have to
kind of grapple with things in some way
are not usually interesting characters
right a character who is sure of
everything a character who never has to
to second guess anything a character to
whom everything comes very easily
is not usually the most interesting
character and you could definitely have
a story where
you know it's like i want to get into
the space academy and all my friends
want me to get into the space academy
and my parents want me to get in
and everybody in the story wants me to
get in but i still have to pass this
exam to get in and i'm stressing out
about it
and like in the end i do get in and it's
a happy ending
but i'm still like oh my gosh am i gonna
get in you know
that could be a story like it nobody in
that story has to be
saying i don't want you to get in or i
think you shouldn't go or you know
you could have a story where and you
could have a story where it's like
about someone who's struggling with a
personal decision where they have two
options which are both good options that
are
you know both neither of them is like
a an a bad or destructive thing to do
necessarily they just have down they
have drawbacks they each have
you can't do both things you have to do
one thing it's like am i gonna go
to germany or am i going to go to france
and they're really
trying to figure out which which awesome
country they want to go to
and in the end they make a choice or
they decide they don't want to go to
either country they want to go to new
zealand
but you know conflict i guess what i'm
saying is
conflict doesn't have to be nasty no i
like the word struggle better because
you can struggle against the universe
not necessarily against other people
right
yeah exactly and like you know and the
other thing is
part of what becky chambers does so
wonderfully in her books i'm just going
to keep
kind of now that i've kind of hit on her
as an example
i'm just going to keep bringing it back
to her but
um part of what becky chambers does so
wonderfully in her books is that
when bad things do happen or when people
are struggling with things
it's an opportunity to show everybody
else supporting that person and being
kind to that person
and being there for that person and you
know
if nothing scary or taxing
or troublesome ever happens then you
don't have that opportunity to show
how we support each other and how we
help each other and how we
hold each other up and so you know
that's the other side of it
okay good i like that i like that
expanded uh conception of what conflict
is we do want
you know it can't be easy you know it's
not that interesting if everything just
happens automatically then that's not
really a very
fascinating story so let's go back into
the nitty-gritty we have
our premise people are talking backwards
we have some characters
i mean at what point do you make
decisions like uh
is it a first person narration versus
third person
is it a novel or a short story are we
gonna break it into a million scenes
like all these nitty gritty things
is this is it is that easy and natural
at this point in your uh
expert life or is it is that the hard
part
no i mean you know i um i will change my
mind about that stuff a lot
um at various points victory is greater
than death
my newest book was third person it was
first person it was present tense it was
past tense it was
oh wow you know and it had different
structures and i feel like that stuff
it's it is annoying if you are going
through and changing first person to
third person or vice versa because
you're always going to miss
like you know a bunch of some pronouns
yeah
pronouns or whatever like the first five
times you go through it like there's
always gonna be like the stray
thing where you forgot to change
something and it's really confusing for
the reader but
hopefully you catch it before it gets
published but you know it's not
it's not that hard to go and change
first person to third person or vice
versa
you know and you often get a certain way
in and you're like the way i'm telling
this isn't the way this needs to be told
and i'm going to go
take a step back and change it or i'm
just going to
keep moving forward but pretend that i
always did it this other way and
later i'll go back and change the first
chunk um but
i think that those kinds of decisions
you know you want to make them at the
start but sometimes you
end up kind of changing your mind and
really the main thing that you need to
think about
that is harder to change once you have a
first draft is kind of just the sense of
tone
and you know vague sense of genre
and like sense of like you know the kind
of
tag cloud or venn diagram or whatever of
what kind of things
can happen in this story and if you're
gonna have going for like a light
whimsical tone
having people getting like maimed and
beheaded on every other page
is gonna unless you're really going for
like
very over-the-top high comedy kind of
splatter
comedy it's going to be really hard to
be light and funny and whimsical with
like
you know beheadings on every other page
and like blood spluttering everywhere
people trying to do it peter jackson
dead alive thing where there's got a guy
with like a lawnmower
you know basically like just shredding
people's bodies
all over the place well quentin
tarantino goes for that quite a bit
right
i guess so yeah there's like splat stick
is like a whole sub-genre of horror
but it's hard you know for the most part
um
you need to make these kind of tonal
decisions because
they do influence the kinds of things
that can be
allowed to happen in the story and so
once you change your mind about tone you
have to go around and kind of
maybe cut out stuff that doesn't fit the
tone you've decided on
and then how nitty-gritty do you outline
the entire plot from start to finish
before you start writing if at all i
mean just have like
i'm gonna get there to the end
eventually which i suspect is
gr martin's uh way of doing things but
uh there's other people who just write
out the whole beat sheet so they know
everything that's gonna happen and then
it's just filling in some details to
actually get it written yeah i mean i
as with most things it varies depending
on the different projects um
in the past i've mostly not been a big
outliner before i start writing
uh with the young adult books uh victory
is greater than death and the sequels
i definitely did a lot more outlining
because those books are much more plot
heavy and there was a lot of stuff where
i was like okay i'm setting up this
thing here and it has to pay off here
and i have to really have an idea in my
head of how this thing works
or else it's gonna really bite me in the
butt later um
so there was a lot more of that with
victories greater than death um
but you know i generally i try to leave
a lot of room for surprises because like
i said earlier
if i'm not surprised myself it usually
means that i'm kind of
sleepwalking through the story a little
bit like surprises are how i kind of
keep
excited about the story and how i keep
invested in what's going on
and um definitely in the case of victory
is greater than death there were a few
things that happened where i was like
this was definitely not what i planned
on but it's way better than what i had
planned on and so i'm going to run with
it
and it's going to change the ending a
lot but i'm going to just i know how to
get around that
um but sorry let me i mean i need to
sort of dig into that a little bit
without hopefully without spoiling the
book but
how exactly does that happen i mean you
sort of
have a vague idea of what the scene is
you're writing and then you start
writing it
and it you just feel it going somewhere
else like i'm trying to
like get a tangible feeling for what is
happening in your fingers as you're
typing here
yeah i mean so i'll give you an example
from victories greater than death which
is like a little bit of a spoiler but
i've actually mentioned it a couple of
other times recently in interviews and i
i feel
good about spoiling this part of the
book because it's something i'm actually
kind of proud of and it's you know
it's i don't think it's it's not a major
spoiler so in victoria's greater than
death the main character is tina
and she's very invested in kind of
living up to this legacy that she's been
given of like being this legendary space
hero
and that's her whole jam is that she
wants to live up to this
heroic legacy that she's inherited
and she wants to save the galaxy and
she's on the path to do that
and so you know in my outline i had like
basically the middle of the book there
was going to be
she's on this alien starship with a
bunch of other kids from earth they're
having adventures
the adventures are kind of getting them
closer to finding this thing
that will help them to unravel the
central mystery of the book
keeping it a little bit vague but that's
kind of the general thing so
that was the outline had that and it was
like okay so
here's just there's gonna be an
adventure here and it's gonna be just
like
some stuff happens and that was
basically what was in the outline and
then i sort of write this scene where
um tina and some of the other characters
are trapped
on a thousand-year-old starship which
was a fun setting to begin with
because you know i love ancient
starships who doesn't
um so tina and the other characters are
trapped on this thousand-year-old
starship
in the middle of nowhere and they're
under attack and
you know as i was writing it i just had
this thing where i was like okay so
because you know everybody else is
incapacitated or
doesn't know how to fight tina is the
only one who can get
them out of this and the only way she
can get them out of this is by killing
the people who are trying to kill them
like this space gun she's got is a it's
basically a gun
it kills it doesn't have a stun setting
because that's not a thing in my world
um because it's not star trek
um so the gun is a it's a gun that kills
it that's all it does
and so and you know tina is like okay i
must i'm
following the footsteps of this space
hero killing people as part of the job
i'm gonna do it
and so she does it and afterwards she's
like i'm fine that was not a big deal
it's all good and then
like a little while later she just has
like an emotional breakdown
and just like completely falls apart
because you know killing people
is actually really scary and intense and
this thing of like
someone was alive a minute ago and now
they're not alive anymore and even if
they were trying to kill you
and they maybe were not a good person
they had thoughts and dreams and
a favorite food and a favorite kind of
music and
they were a person they had an inner
life and you
have put an end to that permanently and
that's huge
and you know and as i was writing this i
was like this should be a big deal this
should not be a thing
that we just like oh okay another
adventure moving on to the next thing
it should be a thing that we to go back
to what i said earlier
that we struggle with tina should
struggle with this everybody should
struggle with this it should be a thing
that we actually
really think about and
once i had that part of the book it
didn't just feel like a one-off
episode in the middle of the book that
kind of was like getting us closer to
the
the plot thing it felt like a turning
point and it felt like the rest of the
book
had to kind of be about that on some
level because
tina's going to keep being in situations
where she has to kill her be killed and
what's she going to do
and is she gonna just keep on killing
people
because that's the easiest way out of
every situation and
so that ended up being like a major part
of the second half of the book
and actually changed the ending of the
book in ways that i won't get into
because that is more of a spoiler and it
changed the rest of the trilogy a lot
because
you know yeah tina made some choices
that
that changes her trajectory for the rest
of the series
and so and you know i felt in the end
really good about that
after i had made that decision but while
i was still in the middle of
writing and revising the book i went to
this panel where these
it was like a panel at the nebulas i
think in 2018 2019 i don't know
at the nebula awards where they had
actual teenagers talking about young
adult fiction it was like everybody on
the panel was
either a teenager or maybe 20 and
they were talking about what they liked
and what they didn't like in in young
adult fiction and one thing that they
kept coming back to is
i want to see violence and the
consequences of violence dealt with in a
realistic way i don't just want
to see killing killing killing with no
thought to the consequences and i was
like
literally sitting there in the back row
in the audience of this panel wiping the
sweat off my brow
because i was like i dodged a freaking
bullet there
i i probably if i hadn't thought about
this if i hadn't just written that scene
and kind of gotten into
the moment i probably would have written
a book where she goes around killing
people and there's never
we never deal with it and i would just
be like yep she's a hero she kills all
these people it's great
but because i had you know randomly
written that scene and it just kind of
hit me this certain way
i ended up with this thing that i think
if those teens ever
get around to reading that book they'll
hopefully feel like i did the thing that
they were saying they wanted to see more
of but
i feel like you know and i thought about
it not to get on my high horse
but you know the more i thought about
the mars like
being a teen in america today with like
all this
insane violence and school shootings and
you know
drills and like not knowing if
somebody's going to come into your
school with an assault weapon
you know it's actually probably really
important to think about this stuff
you know yeah and um and to to and to
not
treat it casually well it's a great
answer to the original question because
it does help illuminate how you can plot
out what you think is going to happen
but then when you're writing you have to
get into your character's heads
right and you might realize like i mean
this is the great challenge of a
of a fiction writer who has multiple
characters which is almost all of them
that it's hard to imagine the full inner
life of many different people who
presumably have different goals and you
know different ideas about things and
you might on the one hand you might come
to realize
that they would feel a certain different
way in a situation but on the other hand
like is is that for you one of the
challenges of just writing fiction at
all
or is that again the easy part i mean
for me that would be hard like i think
that if i did try
all my characters would end up sounding
like me and that would be terrible and
you know
you don't want that yeah i mean so
that's actually two separate things i
think
one is how do you kind of create like
a larger cast or like a bunch of
supporting characters who
feel like people and not like just like
you know
non-player characters or whatever npcs
and then the other question is a
question of dialogue and how to make
people sound different and those are
those are related but separate questions
i think that you know
i mean i've been thinking about this a
lot lately because
i put myself in a situation where this
young adult book has
or the trilogy has a very large cast who
i feel like i need to
everybody needs to have an in our life
to some extent needs to have character
growth over the course of the series and
there's times when i'm like i wish i
hadn't done that because
there's a lot of characters to track
here especially in the second and third
books because you know it just gets
bigger and bigger
um and i do read other books sometimes
both young adult and adult where i'm
like okay so basically there's
two characters in this book who feel
like they have a real and i don't
want to call any specific books but i
read books and is where i'm like okay
these two characters i feel like have a
real interiority and
everybody else is a little bit of an npc
and a little bit of a
you know everything that they say or do
relates back to the main character and
there's never a sense of like this
person really wishes that they were off
doing this other thing yeah like you
know i want to be a golf pro but i'm
going to help you with your thing
for now but the moment an opportunity to
be a golf pro
arises i'm gonna be out of here um
you know i think it's really so that
thing of having
everybody have an inner life among the
supporting guests is tricky
and requires just like you know like
with all the birds in the sky one thing
i did was i sat down and wrote like a
detailed
origin story for like 20 different
characters in the book
because i was like if i know where they
come from and how they got here
and what motivated them before the story
started then i can at least
kind of have a sense of where they're
going and what they're pushing towards
so that was one thing
um the other thing i think
is something i learned from journalism
actually
that has been really helpful in writing
fiction is
i feel like in journalism there's kind
of an unspoken rule and i'm probably
going to get hate mail from journalists
for saying this
but in journalism there's an unspoken
rule that if something happens three
times it's a trend
yeah yep like we all know you're writing
a trend piece you know you're writing a
trend piece for a newspaper
or a magazine and you're like here's
three examples of a thing happening
therefore it's a trend and maybe that's
the only three times that's ever
happened
but if there's three times that's it's
clearly
happening a lot like you know in the
social media era this has become too
much because you can always find three
people on twitter to say absolutely
anything right and so yeah exactly what
people on twitter are saying
i wish tweets wouldn't sometimes i wish
tweets weren't embeddable
because i feel like if tweets were not
embeddable journalists would have to
actually
do a little bit more legwork to find
people saying stuff anyway so
um but that's a whole other anyway um so
once you know that anything happening
three times as a trend
this is so helpful because if you see a
character do something three times
then you feel like you're constantly
seeing the character do that thing and
it's just three times and it can be
a glimpse like oh this character is once
again
obsessing about this thing or yeah and
you can and
you can use that to your advantage of
like okay the first two times we saw
them do it this way but the third time
they did it this way so clearly they've
gone through some change
and we don't really have to like spend a
lot of time on that because
the reader will pick up on it and be
like okay you know
and i think that i've noticed this in my
own this is actually helpful that rule
of
if it happens three times it's a trend
is really helpful in general because
often when i'm revising my fiction in
general i'll have something happen 10
times
because i really want to kind of like
get across this thing is happening a lot
and when i revise i often will be like
you know what i can cut it down to this
happening two or three times and the
reader will still think it's happening a
lot
right because the reader will notice
like people pick up on things more than
you think they will even if they're only
subconsciously picking up on them
so you know that's a really helpful rule
to remember and that's one of the ways
that journalism has helped me as a
fiction writer is knowing that rule of
the three times
which again i apologize to all the
journalists listening to this some of
our best friends are journalists
dialogue thing the dialogue thing is
really hard
and part of it is just you know getting
outside of like your standard
own voice of the way you talk and you
know
i do kind of listen to the way people
talk in real life i eavesdrop
sometimes in an hopefully non-creepy way
i'm out on the street i'll hear people's
snatches of their conversations
i will you know i'll just kind of be
trying to consciously
pick up on how people say things to try
to write naturalistic dialogue but also
i will
with characters i'll try to just like be
like well this character talks more
kind of shorter you know punchy
sentences this character talks in
long run on sentences that are just like
no no no no no no no because they're so
excited
this character will have like i'll give
sometimes i'll give a character a couple
of catch phrases and i'll try not to
overuse it but i'll just be like
this character science says this thing
and i'll just try to let that
seep in and i'll you know you read stuff
out loud in general
the longer i do this the more i feel
like i have to read my stuff out loud
in order to catch stuff because i'm so
used to my own writing style my own kind
of like
that my own kind of writing voice that i
don't
pick up on stuff and sometimes unless
i'm
kind of reading it out loud and just
then i kind of stuff jumps out at me
more
do you base characters on yeah
sorry do you base characters on real
people or aspects of characters on real
people
no not anymore i think i did when i
started out but i definitely have
stopped doing that because i feel like
at this point i've created so many
characters that
i kind of ran out of real people but
also i just
i feel like basic characters on real
people just gets you into trouble
sometimes
not in the sense of like people will be
like oh this character was based on me
because i don't feel like that really
happens by this time it's a fictional
character and a full-fledged story
they've kind of
gone in a different direction but it
just it's kind of a limiting thing and
it kind of keeps you from really
knowing them as a fictional character i
think so i will
really try to i'll just try to come up
with like a
an interesting kind of like like that
what if thing that i talked about at the
start the what if of like oh what if
there was a person who
really wanted to be a doctor but they
were afraid of needles and
so they became this other thing and like
you know i just i'll try to come up with
like a
an interesting kind of spark that gets
me
kind of to start imagining this person
yeah and then i'll just try to run with
that
i should have asked this before when you
were talking about the um
character who shot someone and had to
deal with it but there is a sense
which i i honestly don't think i
understand but a sense in which
stories have a moral point of view right
like
uh not that uh the good people are
necessarily rewarded and the bad people
are punished that obviously doesn't
always happen in stories but
we have the feeling that the story knows
what is good and what is bad and we get
a little annoyed like some people were
annoyed with wand division for example
because they felt that the main
character
did some terrible things that she kind
of just got away with without really
suffering for like is that a is that a
guiding
principle to how you structure your
story should there be kind of a moral
point of view and
and how does the story even have a moral
point of view it's just a bunch of
things happening over and over again
yeah i mean it's it's that's a huge
question that we could talk about for
a whole hour by itself but you know
i guess two things about that one is you
know back when
i was writing for io9 a lot i think that
i was one of the people who was really
pushing the idea that stories have a
meaning
and stories have you know a meaning that
is political and personal
and social and that you know if you
show a character doing a thing there are
ways that you indicate
you know kind of a point of view about
that and that you have to kind of
acknowledge that and if you show
someone going around killing people all
the time you are kind of saying
something about violence in a way
and you know i love action movies i love
james bond movies i love
the john wick movies i love you know i
love
movies that have a high body count don't
get me wrong at all
but i feel like there is a way in which
you kind of
walk away from a movie like that with a
certain feeling about violence
and you know i remember being a teenager
and walking out of a james bond movie
and just like
having this like weird flash in my head
of like yeah i'm gonna go
like get in a fight with somebody not
because i wanted to get in a fight
because i would but i was just still so
amped up
yeah from watching james bond just kill
like you know
oh basically a small army of people
by himself and just like it was like it
wasn't even like an intention it was
just like a flash in my head of like oh
you know fighting and then it was by the
time i had walked out and like
threw on my soda in the trash that was
already gone but it was just
it was like a brief like spark in my
head don't
go telling your listeners that i'm like
a you know i'm gonna
get in a brawl with them or that i'm
like a match murderer or whatever people
draw their own so i think that stories
do have a point of view and i
but i think that more to the point
whenever you are
creating a piece of fiction or a piece
of storytelling you have in your head
an ideal reader or like a person you
were telling the story to and i think
that a lot of times we don't really
think about that
and part of where we get into trouble is
that you know as someone who is white
and you know has a certain amount of
class privilege and stuff my default
is to assume or to kind of picture
in my head that the person who's reading
my story or consuming the thing i'm
creating
is going to share certain
characteristics with me and of course
that's not going to be true
yeah in every case in many cases and so
there's a certain amount of imaginative
labor that you have to do
to kind of project yourself to
a reader who is not you who is not
someone who
shares your viewpoint and i think that
having an ideal reader in your head is a
really valuable thing because it
allows you to kind of be like um
anticipate like somebody's going to
think this is happening and i have to
either
play to that or play against that and
like you know you have to know what the
audience is expecting if you want to
confound their expectations you have to
kind of know
where to how to meet your audience but i
think that at the same time it's
really good to kind of and this is part
of why i hire sensitivity readers it's a
good part of why i try to read
fiction written by people who are not
from my same
you know uh community or my same culture
or my same background
um i think it's really good to project
yourself beyond your own experience in
terms of like imagining your own ideal
reader
and i think that's a lot of where people
fall down um
i don't think i don't ever think stories
need to be morality tales or that they
need to be didactic again we talked
about didactic fiction at the start
i don't think stories have to be like
just so stories where or or
like where like if you do this this will
happen
you know if you kill someone you're
gonna like your head's gonna explode or
whatever
but i think that you should at least
kind of understand
the model of the world that you're
creating for your reader and the kind of
reader that you are create that you
think you're creating that reader
that model for and maybe try to think
beyond
just like you know yourself and your
three friends
well yeah and and uh as the writer you
do have control over not just the events
of the story but
how they are commented on or or what
their repercussions are i think that
the problem with one division was that
you know wanda does some terrible things
and then
uh one of the other characters instead
of saying wow those are some terrible
things
says to her well you know they don't
understand that you've gone through a
lot too
and so that just goes into the point of
view of the story in some sense and and
i i guess one way or the other your
story is going to
be judgey of itself right i mean your
story is going to
render certain things that happen in the
plot as well it's terrible
that that happened but it happened or
yay this happened
yeah i mean i think that like i said
every story has a point of view and
every story has
like is communicating to someone and is
kind of
building a model of the world in a way
and yeah sorry i'm just repeating myself
now but yeah
good i'm glad we're on the same way like
but okay speaking of building a model of
the world again you said a whole bunch
of things earlier on that i don't want
to
let completely slip by um you know part
of
the process for any fiction writer but
for science fiction fantasy especially
is the world building
process right and i guess uh that would
be another topic that i'm sure we could
go on for many hours
podcasting about probably you have right
maybe you should put that in the links
in the show notes
but uh let me ask the single question
you know it seems that
in the real world if we just imagine
what the future is going to be like
500 years from now it'll probably be
different than now
in a million different ways so many ways
that it's almost unrecognizable but
it seems that what a lot of stories do
is to
pick a few ways to highlight that things
are different and then keep other things
more or less recognizable to people
in our current circumstances is that i
guess my question is is that once again
a fair characterization is that a smart
thing to do or
would it be even better to sort of try
to really imagine
how wonderfully different things are
going to be in some very different
circumstances
yeah i mean i think that it's really
hard to imagine a future
and you know account for like a million
different kinds of technological change
and social progress
and you know the ways in which like you
know i sometimes think about how
different the world was a hundred years
ago
or 200 years ago and how foreign our
time would seem to someone from the
early 20th or early 19th century
and i think that we kind of underrate
how
drastic these changes some often are and
how
complex and multi-layered they are
and you know you can kind of go at it
from like
from the direction of trying to start
from now and
forecast your way forward like you know
years and years that tv show that
russell t davies created
um a year or two um which starts in the
present works its way forward i think i
forget like 20 years i can't remember
exactly how far forward it gets but
you know and there's been other things
that do that i think samuel delaney
wrote a book that does that
doris lessing did that in her um martha
quest books
um and it's just it's really hard
because it is kind of fractal or
whatever
and you know there's like every every
single change has a million unintended
consequences and second order effects
and so it's like it just becomes like
this really complicated thing
or you can come at it from the opposite
point of view and do kind of like a
philip k dick
style thing and just be like we're gonna
pick you know 100 years from now and
like just make it
really weird in a bunch of ways and not
really show how we got from here to
there
and just have it be kind of bizarre and
i've definitely done that
like i have a story called i've written
a story called i'll have you know
which was actually adapted into a an
audio dramatization that i really
encourage people to hunt down
and um you know i'll have you know
is takes place like at some point in the
medium-term future probably
100 200 years from now and it's just a
weird you know everything is kind of
augmented reality everything is
you know people are learning in their
sleep people are like
living to be 130 140 years old routinely
everything is just like bizarre and kind
of
off kilter and it's you know it
has a little bit of a cartoony feel to
it because i'm not trying to like
plausibly say well this is exactly how i
think technological and sexual change
will play out it's just more
here's a bunch of wacky stuff happening
and it's kind of a vaguely coherent and
um and um
self you know a self-evident view of the
the future and i think that that's often
safer ground
i think that you know it's never really
possible to
predict even five years from now in a
way that's like holistic i think that
you're going to end up with
you're going to end up missing a lot of
stuff and you know someone five years
ago trying to predict now
probably would have missed a lot of what
we're dealing with right now like
someone in you know march 2016 was
trying to predict
march 2021 there's some stuff they would
not have seen coming
i think so let's just say but you're
i mean maybe uh to land the plane here a
little bit
your most recent novel just coming out
now is a young adult novel which is a
departure
for you uh but it's still science
fiction yes it's still
yeah galactic empire kind of things
saving the galaxy
uh so what what uh pushed you in that
direction what would
would is this a long-standing ambition
that you've had to write a young adult
novel or do you think it'd just be fun
or is that where the real money is
what's going on here
so i've always loved young adult fiction
like young adult fiction
is you know um there's actually a
washington post article from
2011 where i'm just like going on about
how much
i feel like young adult fiction is the
most exciting writing happening so
at least 10 years i've been like really
just a huge fan of y
a and i always thought about writing y a
and you know i had been noticing that
why a had kind of taken a turn like
maybe five years ago i was starting to
notice that y.a was really taking a turn
from being more kind of dystopian like
kind of the hunger games divergent
you know uglies like there was a lot of
dystopian y a for a long time that was
kind of like
a dark future where everything is
terrible and
there was why it seemed like it kind of
took a turn away from that
towards kind of fun action-adventure
storytelling
that was more kind of like you know the
kind of
stuff that i grew up loving and more
kind of like
a space in which you could do your own
version of something like star wars or
guardians of the galaxy or doctor who
and you know i was reading books like
warcross by marie lu
and you know just a ton of other ya
books that were coming out around the
time
that were just super fun and super
exciting and just like
you know had some had angst and had kind
of
emotional stuff in them but also were
just like fast-paced adventures and like
leigh bardugo does all these books that
are just like
super exciting and fun and there are
keepers kind of and they're just like
you know and they're in a world that's
just like really
fun and exciting and there's darkness
but there's also just like
swashbuckling adventures and fights and
we're just you know
it's just that was something that really
appealed to me greatly and i'd always
wanted to find a way to do my own
kind of like just zippy action adventure
thing where i could be like here's my
version of
star trek star wars guardians of the
galaxy
she-ra you know shira wasn't out yet but
you know that became a thing that i
aspired to
um as i was working on this and steven
universe also
i hadn't yet really gotten into steven
universe but
so stuff like that and so you know so i
was like okay maybe it's time for me to
really think about doing a y a
now that there's that now that y a has
kind of taken this turn
in a direction that's exciting to me and
um
and i just thought a lot about like when
i was a teenager what was the thing that
i
was really obsessed with and what was
the story that i
would have wanted to read and what's the
wish fulfillment that i would have
wanted
when i was a teenager kind of because i
love wish fulfillment and storytelling i
think that's an underrated thing along
with escapism
and i really thought about like when i
was a teenager i
desperately wanted a spaceship to just
come down
and land in front of me and be and have
aliens come out and be like
hey you actually belong with us you
don't belong on this
cruddy planet you know come with us you
know we're your real people and like i
still kind of wish that would happen
and um and just like take me away from
earth forever
kind of and so i was just like waiting
for that to happen when i was a teenager
and so i was like okay what if that
actually happened and what if there was
a teenager
who actually did kind of belong in space
and was actually really secretly an
alien and had this awesome destiny and
this awesome
kind of adventure waiting for her in
space and that was my starting point and
then of course because i always want to
make things more complicated and
you know more and it's not you the thing
about wishful felon does there have to
be
complications and problems or else it's
just boring
i was like okay so what are the what
what goes wrong with this or what's the
what are the issues that she's going to
deal with and that kind of
that kind of got into some stuff that
felt really juicy to me about like
what it means to be a hero and you know
i talked before about when she has to
kill people for the first time and how
hard that is and so that kind of
it became it became a way for me to kind
of think about a lot of these stories
that i'd love growing up
and kind of examine them from this other
vantage point
and so and that felt just really fun and
juicy and interesting to me and
and that was kind of the rabbit hole i
went down
uh you know final this is going to be a
sort of uh very down-to-earth question
but um it's not just a book it's a
the first book of a trilogy right i mean
how does that work
do you again plot out the whole trilogy
ahead of time
how does it change the writing of the
first book to know that there's going to
be two books after it
how it works is that i bang my head
against the wall over and over and over
again until
like i'm seeing stars i don't know it's
like this is my first time writing a
trilogy
and you know i keep saying next time
maybe i'll just write one book and break
it into three because
i just or write like a really long thing
and then figure out how to break it into
three things because
gosh it's so hard and like i think that
i mean
you know when i sold it i had like a big
chunk of the first book but i also had
an outline of the second and third books
and then i made a lot of choices in the
course of writing the first book that
drastically changed the second and third
book so i had to go back and outline
them again
and at this point the second book is
basically done and i have a really good
outline of the third book
so you know it's coming along but
there was a lot of trial and error i
mean for me there's always a lot of
trial and error unfortunately there's a
lot of like stumbling in the dark before
i find
the the light switch or the path forward
or whatever um
but yeah truly trilogies are really hard
and middle parts of trilogies are
especially hard because you you can't
resolve everything
you have to like kind of just move
things forward but not resolve
everything
and in this trilogy in particular the
first book
i kind of in the first book tina is
mostly on this alien starship with a
group of other kids from earth and a
bunch of alien characters and they're
this isn't really a spoiler and they're
dealing with like this
quest that they're on and there's a
bunch of stuff where i'm like
well i'll explain that in the second
book oh we can see that in the second
book
well there's all this like bigger
galactic politics stuff
and we'll like we'll explore that in the
second book and then it was like time to
write the second book and it was like
why why did i do that why did i leave
all this stuff for myself to like deal
with in the second book and like
the good news is there's there's nothing
that i set up in the second book that
is gonna be hard to pay off well it's
gonna be hard in the sense that writing
is always hard
but by the time the second book is over
i've already pretty much
shown you everything i need to show you
and the third book is just gonna be
like action because everything's been
established so i'm just
i'm actually dying to get back to the
third book once i hand in the revision
of the second book because i think
that's going to be pure candy like the
second book is a lot of like
a lot of world building because there's
a lot of stuff where i'm like
well there's a galactic society we only
kind of glimpse it in the first book and
we really see it in the second book
and then the third book is just like fun
fun fun fun fun that's good just pay off
yeah but not that the second book isn't
fun no
don't get me wrong i'm not gonna i don't
want you to tell so much fun i don't
want anybody
away from this with the idea that like
the second book is gonna be a slog
in fact i'm really grateful that people
who've read the second book so far are
like
you managed to keep the pace and
excitement of the first book going which
i'm like
thank you that's that's really i was
worried so i'm really glad to hear that
some of us like the world
the second book there's just there's
just more world building that i had to
really work
and there was a lot of like trial and
error with that you know i'm rereading
some of ian banks's culture novels which
are classics of course
but i had forgotten how much of them are
just him like
describing what you know the galaxy and
the culture and all the different things
like
the plot could be literally half the
book you could
you could have the same exact plot but
it's great it's delicious you you eat it
up so i don't think that's something to
be worrying about
what do you think for the audience
members who as a final thought uh
are ready to write their first novels
what are the words of encouragement or
inspiration or education you want to
leave them with i mean what how should
they start
[Music]
uh
writing is fun and you know the thing is
i feel like i mean writing is incredibly
hard and painful and stressful and
and you know there's all this anxiety
especially if you start thinking of the
publishing part of it which is
you know it's a whole other thing um
because it's business and business is
always more kind of
stressful in its own way but you know
the thing is writing
should be fun and there are ways to make
it fun um
and you know just remember to have fun
and play i think be playful
and like you know revel in it at least
some other time revel in the like i'm a
god in my own private universe
i can anything i say goes i can have
everybody be like nine feet tall and
bright pink if i want and nobody can
tell me that
that's not okay and just you know have
fun with it
and like you know there will be horrible
painful awful parts but
there should also be parts where you're
just having fun playing and inventing
stuff and
the other piece of advice i always give
to beginning writers is find ways to
make it communal
find a writing group find people to read
your work to
share your work online go on instagram
live and read your
stuff that you've just written go on
youtube and post youtube videos go on
wattpad
or scribde or i'm not sure it's scribdy
or scribe d but you know
go online share your stuff with people
if we ever start gathering in the real
world
gather in the real world and share your
stuff with people go to open mic nights
go to
writing workshops have a group of peers
that you talk to and you commiserate
with
find community because writing doesn't
have to be this terrible solitary
like lonesome thing it can be a thing
that is a shared experience and
that's often a much better way to go
about it
just you know all the advice you just
gave to writers works equally well for
theoretical physicists
so it might be much more general than
you expected so
wait theoretical physicists are a god in
their own private universe yes
of course you're inventing the laws of
physics come on what do you mean
should be the most fun thing you could
possibly do
all right charlie jane anders thanks
very much for being on the windscape
podcast it's a lot of fun
yay thanks for having me this was a
[Music]
blast
[Music]
you